depuis ce jour dix ans sans profession
de tv le rsa monsieur d'horreur qu'elle
a vraiment cool ça c'est votre famille
sont pas très beau mais le jeu promet
quand même un devil rails et damien iehl
et argent mais les enfants au lit et je
vais dormir a pas de souci je serai à la
maison dans une demi-heure maison maison
meilleur travail qu'a fait on est noir
gois au bon jouet c'est joli c'est très
joli j'aime beaucoup en la lie à des
effets de taux mais qui sait médias
sombre on ne voit rien soit on capte un
fantôme qu il faut aussi sombre dans ta
maison check up and clara elin et adrien
ok donc il veut aller voir ses
petits-enfants les mecs bercy dormez
bien num pas d'un oeuf youth webcam via
des webcams dans la maison mais que non
mais déjà levé qu'il a un gros hockey ça
c'est ma femme gisait déjà mais qu'il a
un gros problème
j'observe tout le monde tard le soir
quoi mais [ __ ] de psychopathe de merde
alors là c'est quoi ce bruit c'est une
bonne idée d'aller souvent voir ta
famille non mais mon gars ok on va
longuement arrivée la lumière bombay ce
texte à l'arrêt bouteille que j'ai mis
une bonne grosse flash dans la tête elle
se réveille pas à quoi c'est génial on
voit rien ça je peux pas un élu et non
attends le truc il fluorescents mais je
peux pas l'allumer quoi ces [ __ ] de
troll c'est quoi ça vient brouiller voir
en bas direct inquiet rentrer dans ma
demeure c'est quoi toutes ces pièces en
balagne à la cuisine temps mais sa
maison est immense quoi c'est un studio
je serais allé très vite quartz et elin
et linky d'or qui comme ça vers la
somalie extrêmement lourd il ya encore
un étage d'accord nous donnez combien
peu tôt mais c'est quoi c'est comme quoi
j'ai déjà entendu tous les soirs ici
quoi mon bébé hausse est même passé là
dedans quoi regarder les carpates bvc du
mensonge pick-up uv caméra est un bon
gars mais déjà qu'il ya une caméra comme
ça chez lui quoi il ya un gros blême
on dirait juste un ipad avec une
application qui envoie de lumière
violette en plus voilà j'adore mes
bureaux s'il ya des trucs les cinq là
mais elle se révèle elle voit son père
comme ça avec une [ __ ] de lampes uv te
vois je le but donkey et lala bordel ça
commence à bien faire
quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi
quoi quoi quoi bon écoutez moi j'aime
biotech ma femme ça suffit ces conneries
là j'en ai marre arrête on me dit quoi
edreams pourquoi et des violons j'en ai
marre je me cache je me cache
prenez mon bébé mais vous n'aurez jamais
j'adorerais que sa façade allégé doha
c'est quoi ça du poison
oi oi oi oi oi oui bonjour gens voient
les petits flashs violée mais attention
à ces dangereux à ta place je
m'accrocherai pas du tout j'aurais peur
en fait je crois que je le cherche
j'essaie de le griller avec la lampe uv
mais j'y arrive pas alors on va regarder
là dessus et on va aller là on le voit
là y'a rien au jeu te bats je te passe
montre toi
il est là il est là il est là il m'a but
[Musique]
bon il est là il est la pâte à choux
verts devant moi mon gars le mec il a
pas de temps ils ont boycotté il se
montre pas le il n'a pas de quoi je
crois la place tout au plus tard la prof
l'a conduit en train d'allumer une télé
ou la voiture ou la voiture c'est la
voilà ce à quoi je vis des coûts trotter
mais dont elle avait fait c'était c'est
un boucher dans une autre vie cette
personne là sont des connaisseurs butin
qu'est ce que tu as fait à ma femme en
plus elle venait de cette pièce qu'est
ce que tu lui as fait ça va brigitte je
t'aime rigide [ __ ] j'ai jamais autant
détesté un jeu d'horreur c'est hyper
stressant nous fait de point de devoir
le but est comme ça là ça me temps mais
sa meute en quoi c'est quoi demandé la
télé à deux secondes je te vois ça va
bien ça sert à ça mais c'est une blague
walla match de mes dix enfants tombent
demeure bon écoutez cette fois j'espère
quoi russie alors aussi on récapitule on
a plusieurs armes on a eu un couteau et
du poison ou dieu sait qu un mois le
fantôme qua non mais sans déconner elle
est là elle est juste la mecque c'est
quoi ça mais je vais me des coups de
couteau malade mais pourquoi pourquoi la
fin je vous avoue maintenant j'aime bien
mode facile expliqué des particules
blanches quand elle est là
voilà la vie d'un homme nul ça c'est
quoi je crois je suis jamais allé là
c'est une [ __ ] de cartes montgallet
quoi dans la cave
ou alors vous êtes que si on la trouvait
qu'on met le spot à côté d'elle on peut
la faire brûler ou un truc du genre
regardez qu'est ce tu fais maintenant
est ce bien la cha cha jack black black
black beach là où la baisse des eaux la
violence attend merlus habitat rifle
alors oui au départ j'ai jamais 8 arrive
comme ça quelqu'un de bête je m'étais
arrêté la piste est payé à flers aussi
ta gueule [ __ ] j'en ai marre j'en ai
marre j'ai envie de pleurer je me
défonce la voix je n'avais pas de crier
ça insupportable quoi vous régaler d'une
petite pièce
je me suis fan
voilà j'ai pas réussi à prendre le faire
non mais là non mais vas-y mais pas que
les photos mais c'est juste impossible
ce jeu aux mecs je lui met un coup de
couteau je la mets dans les flammes jeu
je lui envoie un spot de sucer une lampe
uv quoi tu as même rozinski yannick noah
en moins de 5 secondes avec ça et non
elle résiste encore et encore et ben fox
ouais c'est bien de retour à la maison
ouais ouais or échappe quitté en rouille
est bon en tout cas merci de regarder
j'espère quand même ça vous a plu ben
voilà des fois ça arrive on file des
jeux aujourd'hui c'est arrivé et ça
m'aide mauvaise humeur
n'hésitez pas mm 2 ça vous a plu a pris
au fait comme vous voulez hein si vous
faites pas janvier suppute un fantôme
chez vous mais vous faites vraiment que
voulez vous avez le choix on se retrouve
sa vie dans une prochaine vidéo par tmz
vient exactement bis
[Musique]